have you ever noticed that people
speaking Spanish sound like they're
talking really fast rks personas poco
Familia des con un idioma el parlante
siempre apparent hablar de Macedo de
prisa does this mean they're able to
communicate information faster than
English speakers una Leviton is por las
que is one reason why Spanish sounds are
fast because more syllables are spoken
per minute than in English that if it's
over an analysis has shown the expansion
conveys less information than English
syllables so the information per minute
is almost identical but what about
written language the square format of
Chinese characters appears to fit better
into our central visual field than the
longer slimmer words of English
this led linguists to suspect the
Chinese would be read faster than
English but experiments show that
English readers can perceive seven to
eight letters at once compared to just
two point six characters for Chinese
however those Chinese characters are
denser in meaning than the English
letters and so both languages have
basically an identical reading rate of
380 words equivalent per minute this
suggests that what limits the speed of
our communication is not language but
our cognitive ability to process
information but how can you really
quantify information well the smallest
amount of information you can have is
the answer to a yes/no question like
have you seen the movie frozen yes yes
or no heads or tails we can represent
this single outcome with a 1 or a 0 1
binary digit it's one bit of information
a roll of the dice has six possible
outcomes so three bits of information
are required to cover all the options to
uniquely represent all 26 letters of the
English alphabet requires 5 bits of
information but if you include lowercase
punctuation special characters and
numbers that takes the total number of
symbols to 95 so you actually need 7
bits of information to encode all these
symbols that was first done in 1963 as
the American Standard Code for
information interchange or ASCII for
short now is the next closest power of 2
computers adopted 8 bits as the
fundamental unit of compute
and they called it the bite where they
intentionally replace the eye with a why
so that it couldn't accidentally be
confused with a bit so how much
information does it take to make you
well your entire genetic code is
contained in the sequence of four
molecules represented by the letters T
ag and c in your DNA each of these four
options can be encoded by two bits of
information and multiplying by the six
billion letters of genetic code in your
genome and dividing by eight bits per
byte that yields 1.5 gigabytes of
information so you could fit your entire
genetic code on a single DVD with room
to spare now your body has an estimated
forty trillion cells in it and each one
contains a full copy of your DNA so you
actually contain 60 Zeta bytes of
information that's 60 followed by 2100
spective by the year 2020
all of the digital information in the
world is estimated to be equal to 40
Zeta bytes of information you could
store all of that on 100 grams of DNA
that is less than you have inside your
body but now consider this you share
99.9 percent of your genetic information
with everyone else on earth meaning that
less than one part in a thousand is
unique so the information that makes you
you could be stored in less than a
megabyte you could put it on one of
these a floppy disk you don't know what
that is
in contrast video can contain a lot of
information to specify the color of each
of two million pixels 30 times a second
for this entire video would require a
hundred gigabytes of information but you
can watch this video in HD on YouTube
with just a thousandth that amount and
the reason you can send such a big video
with such a small file size is because
video like Spanish has a lot of parts
that are redundant hey Michael you know
what I've been thinking about reading
about Derek information go on it's a
physical thing it's embodied in actual
objects how's that we know like the
words we say their actual vibrations in
the
err right they're not just concepts they
are real physical things that you could
measure and detect that's true and they
don't go away they don't disappear even
after they've for instance moved through
the air right after we've said these
words they have actually interacted with
everything around us so you're saying
that technically I could look at the
world and if I knew enough about it in
the position of its particles I could
trace back and extrapolate all the
information that's ever occurred through
them or at them that's right you could
in principle figure out exactly what
we've said here today whoa
this episode of veritasium was inspired
by the book the information by James
Gleick you can actually download this
book for free by going to
audible.com/veritasium or you can pick
any other book of your choosing for a
one-month free trial audible is a
leading provider of audiobooks with over
150,000 titles in all areas of
literature including fiction nonfiction
and periodicals now if you've already
read the information you may want to
check out surely you're joking mr.
Fineman by richard fineman it's my
favorite book by a scientist it is
absolutely hilarious you will thank me
for downloading it so go check it out I
really want to thank audible for
supporting me and I want to thank you
for watching